year after year a ton of incredible
films are released only to end up going
largely unnoticed and 2018 is no
different
but they'll worry about missing out on
all the future classics slipping under
the radar we've got the scoop on the
very best adapted from writer Joe Kelly
an artist JM Kenna Maura's graphic novel
with the same name I killed giant stars
the conjuring twos Madison wolf as the
plucky Barbara Thorson an oddball
outsider with her head in the clouds a
pair of bunny ears atop her head and a
Norse war hammer in her bag the
introverted Barbara uses her overactive
imagination to create fantasy world she
can escape to when things get tough at
home and when she's convinced a horde of
Giants is headed to earth she's the only
one that can vanquish them I find Giants
hi Jill science blending together a
coming-of-age tale themes of grief and
denial magical realism solid CGI and
captivating performances from Wolfe and
supporting actors Imogen Poots Zoe
Saldana and Sydney Wade
I killed Giants is a magnificent monster
movie that's monstrously moving murder
is on the menu and writer director Corey
Finley's thoroughbreds a black comedy
thriller that centers around childhood
friends Lily and Amanda reuniting to
cook up a devious plan with the help of
a hired drug dealer turned hitman the
two women plot to take out Lily's
tyrannical stepfather mark the murder
mission takes a few unexpected turns
arriving at an end you won't see coming
[Music]
rarely do first-time creatives get their
debut as right as Finley did with
thoroughbreds despite the film's lack of
big-budget promotion and pre-release
hype Rotten Tomatoes says the handful of
viewers who saw it in theaters were
quote left squirming laughing and
gleefully entertaining an Academy Award
winning directors Sebastian lay Leo's
disobedience forbidden love Parkins back
to Romeo and Juliet but religious
tension pushes it past the breaking
point and headfirst into dangerous
territory based on British author Naomi
Alderman's 2006 novel disobedience stars
Rachel vices Ronit a non-practicing
Jewish woman who returns to her former
Orthodox London community she was
shunned from years earlier for a
forbidden romance with a female
schoolmate rachel mcadams st reunited
years later the two fall back in love
only this time s teased husband David
turns their relationship into a triangle
lay Leo creates a film that swirls with
friction filled stripes and bitter
truths critics have flocked to the film
and David Rooney of The Hollywood
Reporter has praised it saying the
movies soulful reflections on collective
faith and individual freedoms get under
your skin
continuing to resonate after the end
credits of Roald who's taken picture
as commonplace as the 21st century's
technology seems searching is anything
but ordinary set almost entirely on
computer and smartphone screens the
jianchao LED thriller follows David Kim
the father of 16 year old Margot who
goes missing with the help of the San
Jose police David combs through Margo's
computer retracing her online footprints
in the hopes of finding his daughter
what follows is a heart-stopping journey
that grows darker and more complex than
David Mann the audience could have ever
imagined I didn't know her searchings
unique approach well sustained suspense
and a twist you won't see coming make it
one of the best movies of 2018 and one
of the most original thrillers in a long
time
Rafael Castle & Hamilton's daveed Diggs
teamed up to write the comedy-drama you
really shouldn't have missed out on
blind spotting follows Diggs as Colin a
felon nearing the end of his year-long
probation and his best friend Myles
played by Castle a fellow trouble maker
whose influence could cost Colin the
final 72 hours of his sentencing where
Colin longs for a fresh start
Myles is on the hunt for danger in the
rapidly gentrifying streets of Oakland
California their lives splinter when
Colin witnesses a white cop kill a black
man and Myles his thirst for violence
threatens devastating consequences many
movie goers missed blind spotting due to
its limited rollout last summer it's
later wide release came on the same day
as the highly anticipated Mission
Impossible fallout which stole the
spotlight that weekend that left blind
spot II the film Business Insider called
one of the most unique of 2018 just out
of you taking a fantastic novel and
translating it into an equally good film
isn't an easy task where many have
failed before The Miseducation of
Cameron post succeeds as a coming-of-age
drama that serves as a shining example
of what can happen when a silver screen
adaptation does right by its source
material based on Emily M danforth's
2012 novel of the same name the film
centers on Chloe grace Moretz is Cameron
Post who is outed as a lesbian when
she's caught in the backseat of a car
with another girl soon after Cameron's
conservative aunt or
to undergo conversion therapy and a
sensor called God's promise there
Kameron forms friendships with a handful
of other teens who like her put up a
fight against being reeducate 'add I'm
tired of feeling disgusted with myself a
limited release that didn't register on
most people's radar the mis-education of
cameron post has been praised by Glenn
Witt of the Los Angeles Times as a
powerful rejoinder to anyone who'd shame
people into denying their authentic
selves from academy award-nominated
director and co-writer Debra Granik
Leave No Trace begins just before the
boiling point war veteran will played by
Ben Foster and his 13 year old daughter
Tom have been living in an isolated
section of a public park but when the
survivalists duo make one small miss
that social services come calling you
feel safe living with your dead we
didn't need to be rescued your dad needs
to provide your shelter and a place to
live he did they're taken in for
extensive evaluations and set up with
everything they need to live a normal
life hot meals clean clothes stable
shelter in the suburbs school for Tom a
job for will while Tom tries her hardest
to adapt to her new environment and
embrace her surroundings
her father grows increasingly rigid
until he decides to take Tom back into
the wilderness
sweet ride back wearing their clothes
with their house bringing the food we're
doing the world
we have adapted Leave No Trace
definitely made its mark on audiences
who caught it during its limited release
run in June
San Diego readers Scott Marks said the
most incisive point saying Oscar will
remember this movie award-winning
director Steven Soderbergh cast aside
the traditional trappings of filmmaking
and embraces b-movie mojo with unsane a
psychological horror thriller pick shot
entirely on an iPhone 7 plus Claire Foy
leads as Sawyer Valentin
a financial analyst who's moved away
from a hometown in an attempt to evade
her longtime stalker David even hundreds
of miles away so we are still
experiencing the effects of David's
torments and admits to her therapist
that she's had self-destructive thoughts
Sawyer's confession lands her in a
mental institution against her will I
just needed to talk to someone in the
counselor said that I did she tell you
to do this
miss Valentina are you refusing to
cooperate as if being locked away in a
psychiatric hospital wasn't jarring
enough
so you're soon forced to confront her
darkest fear while trapped inside those
walls the only question is is the fear
real or just a product of her paranoia
it must be insane despite its
experimental nature and it being a
soderberg joint unsane didn't drum up as
much buzz as you'd expect still though
it hasn't gone without critical praise
the New Yorkers Richard Brody calls
unsane one of sodor Berg's best movies
the very spark of his artistic passion
all the more reason see it yourself one
part pulpy crime story one part heart
grabbing drama bomb city is a brilliant
little film that made a bang without the
general public even noticing the Jameson
Brooks directed film follows Bryan a
punk music obsessed team from Amarillo
Texas who sticks out like a mohawk
adorned thumb in his conservative town
thankfully there are a number of other
Punk's out there who view Bryan as a
sort of mouthpiece for the movement but
there are an equal number of jocks who
regularly clash with the punks tensions
bubble below the surface then explode
into a violent altercation that comes
with a fatal consequence
I lost my self-control director Brooks
based bomb City on the real-life story
of 19 year old Brian Dennehy a punk who
is killed Anna furious fracas with the
Texas town seemingly clean-cut jocks not
only does the film present the tragedy
of Brian's death and a truthful and
harrowing light it also serves as a
reminder that the American justice
system isn't always moral as Daniel
whites of the Austin Chronicle aptly
puts it the film's message which it
reels like a war chain is a timeless one
don't be such a to people because they
look different from you Joaquin Phoenix
is in top form and you were never really
here writer director Lynn Ramsay's film
adaptation of Jonathan Ames his novel of
the same name
Phoenix gives a darkly fervid
performances Joe a former law
enforcement agent and combat veteran
struggling with PTSD clearly said you
were brutal McCann D post FBI Joe
supports himself and his alien mother by
locating missing and traffic two young
girls on the brink of committing to one
of his many suicidal fantasies Joe's
boss tasks him with binding 13 year old
Nina the daughter of a New York state
senator who offers Joe a sizable sum to
discreetly bring Nina home though Joe is
properly equipped for the job what he
isn't prepared for is the triple-layer
twist and the serine horrors that await
him variety's guy lodge called the film
stark sinewy and slashed to the bone you
were never really here is more than
worthy of the global adulation it's
heavily promoted cinematic counterparts
have received this year